Israel's months-long political crisis
intensified on Sunday protesters blocked
a major highway and set fires in Tel
Aviv in Jerusalem they broke through the
barricades around prime minister
Benjamin netanyahu's residence
netanyahu's firing of Defense Minister
yoav galat gave the opposition to a
Judicial overhaul new momentum golod was
the first senior member of netanyahu's
liquid party to express concerns about
the effect the protests were having on
National Security he tweeted the
security of the state of Israel has
always been and will always remain my
life's Mission I believe that the game
is not over yet and we are heading
towards uh Israel's worst
uh political
and the judicial prices I think that it
will end uh in uh a head-on collision
between the the government and the
knesset on one hand and the Judiciary
the Israeli military raised its alert
level Netanyahu didn't speak publicly
but he tweeted we must all stand up
strongly against refusals the judicial
overhaul would give politicians the
final say in appointing judges and allow
Parliament to override Supreme Court
decisions with a simple majority
Netanyahu says it will strengthen
democracy and balance the courts critics
say the reforms will erode Israel's
democracy the Attorney General says
Netanyahu should not be participating in
discussions of judicial reform while
he's on trial for corruption
the judicial you call it reform it's a
cool it's it's a Judicial vandalism of
of the checks and balances of any
democracy and what we see is the result
in the state is authentic it's genuine
it's spontaneous shortly after Gallant
was fired Israel's Consul General in
York resigned the knesset was supposed
to vote on the judicial overhaul on
Wednesday but there's mounting pressure
for Netanyahu to compromise protest
leaders are calling for a demonstration
in front of the knesset on Monday about
two dozen local Council leaders are
staging a hunger strike in front of the
prime minister's office University
classes are canceled several dozen
doctors have called in sick in protest
and there's talk of a Workers Union
holding a strike a senior member of the
governing Coalition says Netanyahu has
made a strategic mistake
in occupied East Jerusalem